i'm about to piss my pants
[Music]
i'm sorry no matter how hard i planned
something goes wrong
[ __ ] imagine the cops
it's going to be a nightmare
[Music]
this toy camera arrived in the post i
saw it online and with the specs it was
offering for the price
i knew it had to be some kind of joke
cost less than
a quarter of a canon 1d battery for the
equivalent of a kooky alien halloween
costume
but nevertheless the specs said that it
would be 1080p
16x9 it has face detection
[Music]
good morning boy take my new camera
fancy 16 megapixel camera there's
nowhere even for your eye
it's so delayed don't dust my new camera
and only weighs 170 grams which is
0.37 pounds so i thought it would be a
great time to test the discussion of
gear
versus idea by reshooting on what we can
only call a kid's toy
i think it's awesome it's just off maybe
it can only roll for like a certain
amount of time
to be honest and clear we do not operate
this dan's crazy idea super expensive
high production quality ad filled with a
camera
that with all the items needed to make
it work properly comes to just over one
million dollars
here's the top and bottom view sequence
of the behind the scenes
and the end result of part of the high
production quality
get ready for snow snow
shaking
[Music]
thank you and if you want to see the
results of that go watch the video i
just uploaded
called 100 camera versus a one million
dollar camera
that's kind of like the episode one to
this video and then if you do have the
hunger and curiosity to learn more about
how to make a video
i have a class which is available on
skillshare which is an online learning
community with thousands
of inspiring classes for creative and
curious people
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity
through watching my class called
filmmaking for all
tell your story through video i've
watched all the films that have come out
of the students
and it's really inspiring and epic to
see and i'd love to see yours
and then talking about making videos
with nothing but a concept
and great people around you gabby saw
the results of the expensive ad
and like you and joey has no idea how i
recreated it with this
kid's toy so let's dive right into those
questions asked by a far better youtuber
than me gabby the great give it up
everyone
i said just leave the camera it's on
auto focus you can just come
question question how did you do the
thing with this
cheaper camera where you drive the car
up the ramp and then it goes
into the forest so that's what we call a
seamless
transition that shot i flipped because
the turntable could only spin in one
direction
we went up followed the car down
usually what you do is move to black but
that's kind of like cheating
okay because if you go from black to
black it's a noticeable wipe
you know people go oh that's a wiping
point so what we wanted to do
was have enough light projected on that
and then
come out of that exact image into the
turntable
possible with this camera very possible
possible
with any camera okay things like we use
cars wiping parts
and then we come out of the trees into
the office i was really stoked with is
that this
toy still achieved the seamlessness of
the wipes to an extent
just like record go stop recording and
then pick up where you left off
yeah because if you think about it it's
called nissan sense it's a space that
one creates
that only you and the camera as the
viewers see
so we could essentially be anywhere in
the world
and we can merge time and space and come
to a new location
but they can look the same that's where
you go way back before they had
when they were using no no
no no no nobody ever used this they
would never
this is a new thing i'm speaking old
back in the day when you shot on film
and
and you had to you actually had cutting
points with scissors
what you would do is you would make sure
that everything
that you do you try to alleviate the
most amount of post-production
editing that you have to do what could
this camera just not do that the
expensive camera could
so the quick answer to that question
would be everything
an expensive camera is called the dxo
millennium monster
okay do you have to change anything in
your script to make it work with this
camera
no so the point was to to take exactly
every shot
and mimic it with this camera the thing
is when you shoot with
really great quality cameras they come
with a higher bit rate
i won't even get into that latitude
that you can manipulate the imagery a
lot more
in post production so with this camera
what you record
is what you have and it's in a four by
three do you know what a four by three
is four by three is like an
old home video yes crop eyes on this
okay i remember i was very upset when we
got the long one
what you shoot is what you get and
that's a brilliant restriction so you
rehearse and
there's this beautiful synergy that
starts to happen with everybody on set
because they understand
16 megapixels yes that's what they said
and it's also called camera
and we can sand paper off all of this
information a camera has what you call a
sensor
which essentially takes the image from
the lens
and then puts it onto the card and the
card is then what you put into your
computer and you start manipulating this
piece of [ __ ]
has a sensor that i've never even heard
of before you can't do anything with it
you have to take that
and put it in and not touch it but the
shutter angle is so slow
if i go like this and i go to there
it'll still show me what's over there
it's so delayed so was there anything
this
cheaper camera could do that the more
expensive camera
couldn't do time-wise yes hugely
it saved what would take two days
shooting on a set with with the monstro
you could do in five minutes with this
camera if everything's set up all the
lighting
there's no need for a data technician or
a data rank
okay so that's why what i believe
it to be a much more organic video the
limitations
are where the creativity comes through
when you find this
beautiful synergy and synchronicity
between your teammates and people unsafe
with you so then what was
the editing process like from
the toy camera just lightning frost
it was all i think there was only four
shots
for the whole thing and that's all that
i i had
can't manipulate the image so you can't
slow things down
no you can't touch anything so and in
the non-ad ad that you saw
shot on the monster you would notice
that there's no
lines or metal pieces pulling the car
you can't do that i thought it was cool
to then keep in the mental pieces
because it shows intent and action it
did it did it had a very
like nostalgic feel to the the edge on
this
i usually find that there's a lot more
creative nuance
when you're really limited with the
amount of gear that you have
like remember our covered wedding
you know we didn't have guests so i just
made them out of cardboard
there's something beautiful in in
restriction so you never finished film
school
where did you learn like how do you do
all the stuff that you do
okay this is gonna sound like a
legitimate
okay i don't know but i promise you okay
i tried the film school thing
i've tried online tutorials i've read
books
i mean when you have an interest in
something you go out and teach yourself
and this segues perfectly into my brand
read which is skillshare legitimately
i use skillshare so any reliable source
of
edutainment um i'd like to call it it's
fun to watch and it doesn't feel like
education like film school which i
obviously tanked at because it's like
very
boxy and skillshare is the only platform
that i've found that really
it helps guide you and it's from
creators it's made by
other creators that understand and know
things better
than you or than i do recently i watched
animation for illustration adding
movement with procreate and photoshop
to help me better my skills with
immersion skype cooking which is very
artisanal and yeah and you would like
this there are no ads
it's created specifically for learning
because there's nothing more irritating
than going on trying to learn something
and then being bombarded by an ad that
like just sways
sways you and then next minute you find
yourself buying a creative
red bull or like some sites you don't
even know about
it's good for focus they're always
adding new premium classes for you to
take your creativity to
wherever you want to take it to and it's
less than ten dollars per month with an
annual subscription
and you know what's even better the
first 1000 subscribers that click on the
link below
get a free trial of skillshare premium
membership
other than that don't forget you're
awesome brew and i'll see you next week
where i'm making a video about going to
mars
like that's not why are you laughing you
know it's real
i know it's real that's coming next week
subscribe notifications you know
the whole thing be like wow i learned a
lot at least or something
well i hope you learned i'm sure gabs
learned
yeah i can work a camera now
see you next week
[Music]
you